[Musica]
ciao mi chiamo marco ciao mi chiamo
marco sanavio anche tu beh sai io nella
mia attività mi occupo anche di
formazione dei giovani all'uso critico
degli schermi digitali
anch'io mi occupo di educazione dei
giovani all'uso critico degli schermi
digitali
senti se c'è una cosa che io adoro ad
ora adoro ai quando i miei amici
siciliani mi mandano una cassetta di
limoni e allora posso toccarne la
superficie rugosa posso annusare il
profumo di taglio e gusto l'aspro del
limone in bocca anche duro tentare i
limoni per sentirne il sapore aspro
ecco no questo non lo puoi fare se le
prime due cose che ho detto teoricamente
potevi farle per esempio nella dg sfera
tu potresti essere una mia telepresenza
che ne so
im pediatria dove io non posso entrare
nelle stanze sterili oppure in un'aula
di scuola dove io faccio formazione dei
ragazzi però i limoni non li puoi
gustare e soprattutto tu in questo
momento non ha e coscienza di esistere
e c'è un percorso molto interessante e
recente rispetto alla fiction che
racconta di un parco collocato tra le
montagne rocciose il pacifico nel west e
si chiama west world all'interno del
quale ci sono degli avatar sintetici
molto evoluti e questi avatar sintetici
possono essere distrutti possono essere
uccisi violentati perché durante la
notte vengono ripristinati e viene loro
cancellata la memoria però c'è un
problema dentro questa vicenda gli
avatar
un po alla volta acquisiscono la
coscienza dentro un labirinto un dedalo
di coscienza rischiano di diventare più
intelligenti del loro creatore che in
questa fiction è il dottor ford
impersonato da anthony hopkins e quindi
è quella che noi temiamo come
singolarità tecnologica cioè la creatura
che a un certo punto si ribella alle
regole del suo creatore
allora partiamo dall'inizio proprio da
principio e adesso ho visto una tecnica
che ho usato prima un relatore vorrei
tentarla anch'io vi faccio una domanda
quanti di voi alzate la mano sapere la
tecnica dei motivatori alzate la mano
quanti di voi avete sentito parlare
della vicenda di adamo ed eva sulle mani
buono direi che questa è quasi
universale e adesso però andiamo dentro
la vicenda allora nella bibbia c'è un
libro che si chiama genesi che racconta
la cosmogonia l'inizio del mondo e
dentro questo libro si narra la
creazione di adamo inteso come genere
umano e si narra nel primo capitolo e
poi nel secondo capitolo si narra di
nuovo la creazione di adamo come se
tutto quello che c'è stato nel primo
capitolo non fosse mai avvenuto quindi
viene narrata due volte la creazione
dell'uomo quanti sapevano questa cosa
sulle mani qua già il numero si starà
stremando quindi è una vicenda complessa
di cui magari non si è letto tutto non
si è sentito parlare del tutto e la
terza cosa che volevo chiedere poi ho
finito
è questa quanti hanno sentito dire che
nel giardino di eden c'erano due alberi
uno era l'albero della vita di cui si
poteva mangiare l'altro era l'albero
della conoscenza del bene e del male che
però era stato vietato da dio quanti
sanno che gli alberi erano due e anche
qui progressivamente ci riduciamo però è
così gli alberi erano proprio due è la
cosa che mi ha colpito tantissimo
leggendo questo primo libro della bibbia
che al di là del fatto che uno creda o
non creda rimane un'opera letteraria di
altissimo valore quindi fermiamoci anche
solo all'opera letteraria
c'è un suo studioso un esegeta del sesto
secolo che si chiama procopio di casa
che getta uno sguardo originalissimo
su questa vicenda provo a descriverlo
allora procopio dice quando un re voleva
affermare la sua presenza rispetto a una
popolazione metteva delle statue per
esempio nelle città lontane oppure le
metteva al limite del giardino per dire
che anche quando è occupato in un altra
attività
il re dorme o il re in qualche modo
impegnato in battaglia
la sua statua il suo avatar è presente
quindi è un problema di presenza
ora la cosa interessante è che anche il
dio di genesi fa una sua statua e la fa
siccome deve essere lui è la sua
telepresenza la fa a immagine e
somiglianza
ora qui con marco piccolino e forse sono
andati vicino per via della statura ma
per il resto c'è ancora della strada da
fare mentre il dio di genesi la sua
statua la crea da una parte ghezzal menu
e vedete alle mie spalle il termine
ebraico che indica questo c'è a nostra
immagine quindi proprio una copia
conforme
però poi dice il testo di genesi chi the
mood è nu c'è il creatore prende un po
di distanza dalla sua creatura quindi è
secondo la nostra somiglianza ma tra il
creatore la creatura c'è una differenza
ora i sovrani antichi mettevano le loro
statue di fango di terra di terracotta
come adam che è una statua di terra
color ocra le mettevano nel giardino ma
il dio della genesi fa una cosa
straordinaria
soffia nel naso di questa statua nella
operazione di rianimazione che ben
conosciamo soffia nel naso per darle la
vita e pensa un po la parola spiritus
vuol dire proprio soffio cioè è chiaro
che quando la vita entra dentro un
essere umano comincia a respirare quando
la vita se ne va e saliamo
un respiro quindi spiritualità spiritus
vuol dire che c'è qualcosa di profondo
di vitale che ci anima che ci rimette al
mondo anche dopo tutte le fatiche della
vita
però c'è qualcosa che non va per cui
questo adam e la sua compagna si
ribellano a dio mangiano di un frutto
che non è una mela ma è un frutto
improvvisamente scoprono che hanno
sbagliato che hanno trasgredito una
regola e sottraggono la loro presenza ci
pensano di risolvere le cose
togliendo la telepresenza ma dio fa loro
una domanda dove sei
mi ha impressionato questa domanda
perché nel 2005 ho letto un saggio di
maurizio ferraris che si intitola
proprio dove sei ontologia del
telefonino
beh concediamogli questa parola
telefonino perché siamo nel 2005 e lui
dice sai questo strumento che è entrato
nella nostra vita per distribuire la
presenza sta creando un antologia delle
cose diverse degli oggetti sociali
diversi ci stiamo muovendo in un sistema
di assi cartesiani che è sotteso tra
immaginazione e sapere tra soggetti e
oggetti festa proprio cambiando
quello che noi riteniamo l'essenza delle
cose se heidegger diceva esserci nel
mondo a lui viene da dire l'esser c per
il telefonino
va bene allora la nostra presenza
risulta oggi sempre più distribuita
perché è chiaro che attraverso i nostri
dispositivi digitali siamo presenti in
molti posti e possiamo essere anche
presenti contemporaneamente in diversi
luoghi ma è anche di ferita perché per
esempio io potrei dare a marco delle
istruzioni adesso è lui potrebbe
eseguirle durante la notte quindi la mia
presenza continuerebbe anche quando io
dormo come proprio quel re che aveva
messo la sua statua nel giardino ma è
una cosa incredibile pensate derrick de
kerckhove che è un pensatore moderno
che mette insieme un po la tecnologia
con l'impatto che quest'ultima ha sul
genere umano ha detto una cosa se
nell'era pre elettrica per noi
occidentali era fondamentale vedere per
percepire la presenza l'era elettrica ha
modificato questa idea e quindi abbiamo
acquisito una percezione aumentata una
tattilità aumentata dall elettricità e
quindi non era più un punto di vista ma
un punto di essenza beh oggi a me
verrebbe da dire che tu ci sei viene
completato nel tuo essere da un punto di
connessione bene siccome questo è
faticoso allora abbiamo immaginato di
governare un po la presenza per aiutare
i più giovani con la dottoressa luce
maria busetto una psicologa
psicoterapeuta abbiamo inventato un
metodo molto semplice dove noi
ascoltiamo le persone e quindi in
qualche modo i più giovani possono dirci
dove sono chiediamo loro dove ti stai
collocando in questo momento che che
sonia e per il tuo futuro che cosa ti
crea dei vuoti dentro
poi troviamo la loro presenza in una
fase simbolica poi passiamo un momento
di riappropriazione dove uno deve
rendersi conto che è ha perpetrato
qualche è qualcosa di dannoso nei
confronti dei suoi simili dei suoi pari
quindi devi prendere coscienza che la
tecnologia ti ha creato anche qualche
disagio e poi alla fine una fase auto
normativa dolo dove loro stessi decidono
come regolare la loro presenza nella dg
sfera e per gli adulti per gli adulti
proprio nel maggio 2018
abbiamo lavorato insieme con teologi con
filosofi della scienza e con esperti
della dg sfera alla dichiarazione di
padova pensate venata proprio qui ed è
una serie di indicazioni per prendere
per assumersi una responsabilità
nell'ambiente digitale per essere
educatori e dei più giovani per fare
attenzione a tutti quei fenomeni della
vita nel digitale che possono andare dal
gioco d'azzardo che ha molte volte
e gli averi le casse delle nostre
famiglie fino al cyberbullismo sino al
furto di dati perché proteggere i dati
dei più giovani ed i più anziani oggi è
indispensabile perché qualche volta li
carpiscono e loro non sono in grado di
difendersi nella maniera adeguata
ecco che allora questa dichiarazione è
un primo passo un sasso gettato nello
stagno perché l'etica del digitale ci
possa in qualche modo consentire di
vivere bene in questo pianeta
beh qui siamo a padova e giustamente
siamo nella città di sant'antonio che
chiamiamo il santo senza nome pensate
che proprio lui un giovedì santo mentre
stava praticando nella cappella di san
pietro al quadrivio nel castello di
limone
forse aveva un'agenda con dei buchi gli
venne in mente che doveva essere invece
nel coro dei frati a proclamare una
lezione quindi apparve
contemporaneamente in due posti per
poter predicare il giovedì santo e per
poter tenere la sua lezione non mancare
di parola con i frati questo si narra
nella vita di galdi nati una delle
biografie del santo ma se da una parte
affascinante e a me piace moltissimo
distribuire la mia presenza negli
schermi digitali mi piace distribuirla
anche attraverso degli avatar degli
automi ho scelto per questo talk di
spogliarmi di tutti i miei dispositivi
digitali perché volevo gustare la vostra
presenza
ed è stato un bel regalo e poi un
piccolo dono da parte mia volevo essere
qui tutto quanto per voi senza
distribuire la mia presenza nei limiti
che mi consente la mia pelle e quindi
per me è stato bello
qualche volta bisogna darsi anche dei
limiti nella iblis che vorremmo avere
restare nella nostra presenza e forse
riuscire a regolarla un po di più ci fa
anche bene grazie
[Musica]